ouf et alors suite j'ai couché avec à
toi de découvrir quelques chroniqueurs a
vu cette anecdote j'ai servi d'alibi à
une personne un fidèle pendant des
années ouais je sais pas moi je connais
pas les réponses a bah moi si j'étais
toi moi je moi je sais pas je le sens
j'irai sur une fille ça va moi aussi moi
je sens bien beinheim eh bien non à oui
j'avais une hésitation avec qui a garé à
la gueule ah non non lci radio est un
fidèle
heureusement moi j'aimerais peut sur bnl
à cela dit ouais mais on peut pas tout
mathieu c'est moi je me servira bien de
mathieu par exemple acheter un amour et
mathieu je sens qu'on peut lui faire
contre la patience et vous alors
absolument pas non c'est vrai qu'on peut
me faire confiance et qui viendra cbd
alors là oui dans quelle galère en fait
au départ je ne savais pas que j'étais
la libye ah ouais c'est quand le copain
appelé à la maison que j'ai compris que
j'étais un alibi et qu'il fallait que
trop vite une solution et que la trouver
eh ben j'ai trouvé bah oui ben en fait
j'ai dit que j'ai dit qu'elle s'était
qu'elle s'était blessée et qu'on était
en route un gouffre non mais si fusion
au plus bas les énormes alex trouve un
truc qu'on était en route pour la
pharmacie et qu'elle m'attendait en bail
que moi je préfère le cheval se trouve à
fermer la maison et qu'elle était
qu'elle attendait un problème c'est 80
pour la blesser vraiment d'argent
qu'elle était en bas et oui voilà et
jamais cru ça de valérie un bon aussi je
savais pas et quand quand elle le
compagnon qui appelle et que c'est toi
ton ami gbagbo est certain a mis fin
d'emploi toujours cette même source les
amis que cfm a prêté de tes prises en a
bah oui bah oui bon de toute façon elle
a quitté la paix la personne en question
qui mérite avec lula sauf le graff alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres je vous le
dis moi sur ma vie j'ai j'ai attribué
des jours de la semaine à deux personnes
différentes
ça veut dire qu'on pense à moi je
réponds agathe aujourd'hui la partager
la semaine avec 2 me alors qu'il était
agacé à chaque fois non non non non non
je n'en ben jamin nord s'il n'y a pas
assez de jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chante ça semble ça sent bien j'en
prends même pas la question jean michel
alors c'est pas grave c'est qu'on prend
pas très calme intelligent et infidèle
donc y en a pas sa cote autour de la
table 1 à tisséo naulleau ou agathe ou
de leur propre tête intelligente de
sagatta les a gâtés par agathe c'est
vous ah oui c'est moi à les mecs
salut c'est moi mais c'était face à un
dilemme j'ai trouvé une solution on
était en cm1 et raphaël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah ouais bah oui mais moi c'est mince à
cause de la semaine dernière
voir mon patron je ne suis pas un fidèle
voilà bomba très bien alors d'occident
mais parce que j'ai vu cinq niveaux
voilà donc c'était au cm1 samassa pas là
y'a prescription agathe c'est bon au
bout on vous paie même pas comment
souvient de ça on se tue à mascate
c'était toute ma main la faisant on
avait fait des croix sur les sur les
agendas et tout donc c'est une fête se
déroule en deux pendant ce temps on
roulait pas des ballons se tenait la
main on se donnait des stadiers que
c'est pas financièrement quand il a
envoyé par erreur à son ou sa partenaire
une photo de lui ou d'elle en train de
faire l'amour et c'est le cas au crible
les médias l'horreur c'est plutôt facile
de les abaisser
c'est jean-michel alors c'est qu'il ya
trop peu de gens célèbres c'est facile
bah je pense que c'est mathieu mathieu
fils vont me lâcher maintenant beaucoup
moi aussi c'est pour ça je le sais pas
moi c'est qu'il est plus mal c'est moi
j'ai honte à ma vie c'est terrible et
tout ce qui s'en veut toujours faire le
malin banon mais j'étais c'est vrai que
j'aime bien photographier
[Applaudissements]
à
voilà oui alors on veut garder je
devrais moi c'est regarder souvenir
parce que je m'attache pour ce faire
vous prenez sous une rarement des
souvenirs de deux monuments rêve à
savoir et bien enfin mon coin je prends
une photo d'un acte sexuel avec une
personne que j'aimais beaucoup mais qui
n'était pas ma partenaire officiel mais
je vois la photo et abbott qui l'a qui
fait aussi m'a dit [ __ ] si tu arrives
là des signatures mine d'or à séduire
honteux à kiné mais comment on fait pour
prendre une photo pendant l'essai sa
noria qu'une position parce qu'ils
expliquent et ont pu déjà formulé donc
alors du coup je fais une photo et je
l'envoie se dit potes qui m'avait dit
prouve moi que c'est que c'est vrai que
tu l'a cédé des couches dont la photo
est comme moi je pense est forcément par
culpabilité à ma partenaire officiel je
cherche son union et inconsciemment je
tapais numéro de main à main partent à
la faute aux partis et je tape on n'a
pas le même tir alors salorges et
techniques pour ça tout de suite faut
mettre sur mode avion même quand tu l'as
lu je vais finir ma d'avion sa part
aprilia rsa va t'arriver ça c'est pour
ta pas pas du tout avec une fille mais
ça m'est arrivé un jour y réalisa battu
ont maintenant
vas-y bah oui évoqué un film pour luc
besson ouais et le soir on a varié d'eau
qui c'est lui qui produisait c'est un
film qu'il avait écrit que je réalisais
et le soir on n'est pas d'accord sur le
casting et on s'engueule un peu comme
bob bell par texto et hindi ballet à
demain à demain à 7h30 de ma femme ma
belle jurés pont et besson me disent que
t'es réveillé
donc j oui et ça reprend la discussion
et ma femme envoie est ce que toi t'es
réveillé giresse a fait une demi heure
je me prends la tête avec l'autre pas de
couilles de besson non et j'envoie
victoire [ __ ]
ça irait moi moi moi tient à envoyer un
sms comme ça aussi un chroniqueur de
laurent ruquier
non je cherchais son numéro et il dit
ouais il yal'autre condamne una qui
cherchent de nouvelles rames kraft foods
et me voient ils appellent jeudi alors
t'es trompé non mais c'est pas du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors il est encore vivant aujourd'hui
oui allez n'est plus dans le paf j'ai dû
occuper la maîtresse d'un ami pendant
qu'il était avec sa femme
en fait cela revient beaucoup ça ouais
commencent à occuper la nage pas compris
occuper la mecque j'ai dû occuper donc
la maîtresse d'un ami pendant quitté que
sa femme ça devrait être le contraire
d'occuper la femme mais il va nous
expliquer ce qui s'est passé naulleau ça
c'est compliqué c'est de l'eau chez moi
quelquefois c'est un manille à un ami
très proche qui avait donné rendez vous
en même temps à sa femme et à sa
maîtrise chez lui non il me dit ça a
joué à dix minutes c'est vrai tu emmènes
la maîtresse ou tu veux je suis dit j'ai
pas tellement envie de sortir ce soir
est menée si tu as envie de sortir
je te prête ma bagnole je te suis le 200
balles dégage ouais à l'airé du passé
la fille je ne la connaissais pas je
n'avais jamais vu de ma vie en est il a
réussi à la convaincre de passer la
soirée au restaurant avec maintenant
c'est ouf
elle a ensuite j'ai couché avec elle
[Applaudissements]
ces jeunes n'ont plus qu'à gagner 200
bain
[Applaudissements]